fortunately supply has been increasing
and last week we sent more than 2.5
million tests to pharmacies and ahs
locations across the province
we started making rapid tests available
to the public in mid-december
at participating pharmacies in edmonton
red deer and calgary as well as 150 ahs
sites in the rest of the province
last friday we invited more pharmacies
to join the rapid test program
since then another
633 pharmacies across the province have
signed up and ordered tests
that brings a total of
1453 pharmacies distributing tests to
the public across the province
i want to thank everyone in those
pharmacies for their support
this is just the latest example of a
partnership that has been one of the
strengths of our coveted response from
the start
i also want to thank all albertans for
your patience
and the the time it's taken to
distribute these tests as we work
through the supply chain issues
now we're shipping another two million
tests to the pharmacies starting this
week
and all pharmacies should have received
stock by next week
participating pharmacies will be added
to the blue cross website as they
receive their tests
the list will continue to be updated as
supply levels change
so if you're looking for a test
please check the website
with this expansion we're switching to
distributing tests only through
pharmacies
ahi ahs sites will no longer receive new
shipments
that said tests were sent out to ahs
locations last week so some
ahs sites may still have tests available
as a reminder
every albertan is eligible for a free
test kit every 14 days as supply allows
just show your alberta healthcare card
to get a kit
you can also pick one up for another
person as long as you have a photo or
copy of their healthcare card
we'll keep shipping rapid tests to
pharmacies throughout february as we get
them in
looking beyond this month we'll evaluate
the rapid test program to determine how
many more tests we need and for how much
longer
because
and we can finally say this we're past
the peak of the omicron wave and we're
transitioning to life on the other side
of it
now that does not mean the pandemic is
over or that we're still not at risk
there's still substantial strain on our
health care system and there will be for
some time
we need to live with omicron
and that means acknowledging that it's
still a risk
we may need
we may need restrictions again if we see
a resurgence and we need to keep working
hard to promote vaccination because
that's the surest and least intrusive
way we can keep covid at bay
but right now it's time to move forward
the evidence supports it
and it supports the decisions we've made
throughout the omicron wave over the
past few months
we've kept businesses and communities
open and we've done this safely
we've reopened schools safely
and we have avoided overwhelming our
health care system
we did prepare for the worst a wave of
cases that could drive hospital missions
critically beyond our normal capacity
we were open with albertans it was a
real risk and we supported ahs in
preparing for this risk
but it did not happen
the number of patients in our non-icu
hospital units overall remained below
their normal capacity and below the
numbers at midwinter in the five years
before covid 2015-2019
the purpose of restrictions from the
start of the pandemic has been to avoid
overwhelming the health system and help
protect albertans
it's now clear that this overwhelming of
the health system has not happened and
it looks like it's not going to happen
now restrictions have a heavy cost of
their own and so it's time to move
forward starting with canceling the
restrictions exemption program
it did its job and now the need for it
has passed
albertans can still download their proof
of vaccination but the qr code reader
apps will no longer be available
now does this mean this is just a normal
year or that everything is fine
no it does not
the numbers of patients in our hospitals
are in line with midwinter and past
years but the strain on our system and
our staff
is still high
the pandemic has been the toughest time
they've ever been through
and we owe them a huge debt of gratitude
and once again i want to say thank you
to all of our frontline healthcare
workers doctors and volunteers that
support alberta patients
our health system has been through the
equivalent of five winters in the past
two years people are exhausted and i
understand that
the system needs relief
and it is coming
new admissions of covet positive
patience peaked over two weeks ago
and they've dropped every day since
provincially they're down by nearly a
quarter
in edmonton where the peak admission
rate was highest they're down by fully a
third
that means that the number of patients
in a hospital will drop it will drop
soon
and fast if we look at the experience of
other jurisdictions that are ahead of us
on the omicron curve
the details vary
but the trends remain the same in
ontario for example the number of
patients in hospitals started to drop
about a week after new admissions
started to drop
it's down by half in the past two weeks
i know some people think we should have
waited a little longer to see the
numbers in hospital drop in a sustained
way but that assumes the number in
hospital is critically too high right
now and the fact is it's still within
normal capacity and are non-icu
it's higher than 100 at some sites but
the levels at those sites are also in
line with mid-winter non-coveted year
in fact i see ahs today announced they
no longer need
the temporary over overflow overflow
covid sites that were established in
edmonton and in calgary
so the question is
are the number of patients critically
too high right now like they were in the
icu in the fall during the fourth wave
the answer clearly is no
and that's why we don't need to wait
hospitalizations are a lagging indicator
we know roughly where they'll go based
on the case data and the new admissions
data
we know the peak of omicron cases is now
weeks behind us and base this is based
on wastewater and pcr testing data
we currently just have over 25 000
active cases down 25 percent in the past
week and down
by almost two-thirds from the peak of 71
600 on january the 16th
based on all of that
we firmly believe hospitalizations will
continue to trend down in the coming
days and weeks
even as the restrictions exemption
program and mandatory masking for
children and youth come to an end
now we recognize that all albertans have
their own individual risk tolerance and
they have a right to feel safe in their
own way
some may be more at risk themselves or
live with vulnerable vulnerable people
who are more at risk for severe outcomes
from coven 19.
or indeed some may be parents
who want to protect their young children
who are not yet eligible for vaccination
i only ask that we give each other the
space and consideration we all need to
navigate through this transition period
please respect others people's choices
and understand that we are all coping as
best we can with this pandemic
and know that the health system is there
for you if you need it emergency
departments and ems are under a
particular strain due to very high
volumes
of patience and strain on staff caused
by covit but our hospitals and other
services are functioning and they're
safe thanks to the dedication of all of
our health care workers and doctors who
work in them in fact hospitals are still
doing near normal volumes of surgery
over 90 percent of pre-covered levels
the waiting list is actually down
slightly in recent weeks
this reflects lower levels of referrals
due to the pandemic and that demand will
come back as we get the system back to
working normally
the system is going to continue to be
challenged as we gear back up
covet is not a light switch that we can
just turn on or off
but it's important to recognize the
system is there for you
one of the things that keep me and other
health ministers across the country
awake at night is the thought that
people are not coming in for care when
they need it apart from any reductions
and services
so if you need help please come forward
and get it and please continue to do
your part and get all the vaccine doses
that you're eligible for so we can keep
moving back to a more normal life and a
more normal functioning of our health
care system
as of today 40 of fully vaccinated
albertans 18 and older
have received a third dose of coven 19
vaccine to increase their protection
against the virus
this is good progress
but we need more eligible albertans to
get this additional protection
unfortunately we have seen a slowdown in
booster doses over the last week or so
we do have an ample supply of both
moderna and pfizer doses available so if
you've been putting off getting that
third dose because you wanted a
particular vaccine
there's no need to wait
book your booster shot today
in closing once again i want to thank
albertans for their perseverance
and the sacrifices they've made to get
us to where we are today
we can reopen safely because albertans
stepped up again
and did the right thing to protect each
other and to protect our health care
system
and our health system is continuing to
deliver high standards of care because
of the dedication of our health care
professionals
to every one of them once again i want
to say thank you and i look forward with
working with you
so our system can recover from the
pandemic and build an even stronger
system in the future for us all
so thank you and with that i'd like to
turn over the mic to dr hinshaw for
today's update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
over the last 24 hours we have
identified 1363
new cases of covet 19 and completed
about 4986
tests
our positivity rate for lab confirmed
cases is about 29.3 percent
turning to hospitalizations there are
currently a total of
1586 people with covid19 in hospital
including 126 in the icu
sadly i must share that 22 new deaths
were reported to alberta health over the
last 24 hours
i send my sympathies to the family and
friends grieving the loss of these
albertans
their passing leaves a hole in their
communities as does the loss of anyone
from any cause
as of february 10th alberta education
has advised only four of the more than 2
500 schools in alberta are currently
shifted to temporary at-home learning to
address operational challenges
alberta education will continue to work
with school authorities on shifts to at
home learning and all requests from
schools to shift to at home learning so
far have been approved
it is encouraging to see a continued
declining trend
less than one quarter of one percent of
schools are now on temporary at home
learning
today i have some updates to share
the first is that effective february
16th
fully immunized workers in continuing
care will be able to resume working at
multiple facilities
i have talked about this change
previously indicating that it was coming
this move is intended to help facilities
avoid staffing challenges brought on by
limiting workers to a single long-term
care or designated supportive living
facility
it is also supported by operators and
other continuing care stakeholders many
of whom were consulted throughout the
fall and winter
the single site staffing requirement was
originally implemented in april of 2020
to reduce the risk of covet 19 spreading
across multiple facilities and putting
residents and staff at risk
as you remember the early weeks and
months of covid19 saw high case numbers
and continuing care which sadly led to
outbreaks and deaths among residents
fortunately vaccines have been extremely
helpful in reducing the risk of severe
outcomes
and we can now remove this restriction
on fully vaccinated workers to mitigate
the risk of sites not having enough
workers to care for patients
the overwhelming majority of residents
and staff are fully vaccinated against
covet 19.
approximately 80 percent of residents in
long-term care and designated support of
living have received three doses of
vaccine
continuing care facilities will continue
to have covet 19 protocols and outbreak
procedures in place as part of their
day-to-day operations
these safety protocols including
continuous masking enhanced cleaning and
disinfection health screening upon entry
testing and isolation when required will
continue at these facilities to protect
residents and staff until step three
i want to recognize and thank the many
operators administrators and staff in
these facilities for the excellent
quality of care being provided
and for managing resource demands
throughout the last two years
this has been challenging and exhausting
and i appreciate your work
your efforts have helped prioritize
staff and resident safety throughout the
pandemic
the next update i have is about third
doses for adolescents between the ages
of 12 and 17 who have underlying health
conditions
and also those in this age group who are
first nations metis or inuit
bookings will start next tuesday
february 15 15 for these youth
the additional clinical risk factors
include underlying medical conditions
such as diabetes asthma and other
conditions that may put them at greater
risk for severe covid19 illness
the list can be found on the alberta
government's website
in addition adolescents between the ages
of 12 and 17 with immunocompromising
conditions
will be eligible to book a fourth dose
this expansion comes at the
recommendation
of both the national and alberta
advisory committees on immunization
because youth with these risk factors
may be at higher risk for severe
outcomes
at this time there is no recommendation
for third doses for all children and
youth since the two-dose vaccine regimen
remains very effective against severe
disease for this group
also beginning next tuesday we will open
up third dose bookings for children aged
5 to 11
who have specific immunocompromising
conditions as a part of their primary
series
this is the same approach we have taken
in all age groups for those who are
undergoing cancer treatment taking
immunosuppressive medication or who have
another condition that lowers their
immune response
for these people a third dose in their
primary series is needed to get closer
to the response that
non-immunocompromised people have after
two doses
if your child is eligible and the
recommended time has elapsed
please consider getting them their
booster dose as soon as possible
this is a time of transition and change
is always hard it is especially
difficult when we are all exhausted from
constant change over the past few years
and our communities are polarized
as much as possible i ask that all of us
seek to be gentle with ourselves and
others
we need each other in our communities
and that will never change
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr henshaw uh no one in person
here in edmonton i think no one in
person in calgary either so we'll go
straight to the phones please we'll take
the first caller
thank you matt whitman cpb
hi there my question is for dr hinshaw
we delayed the beginning of school so
schools could prepare for kova this was
at the beginning of january
the province ended up ordering millions
of masks to protect kids in schools
they're beginning to arrive now but
starting monday they'll no longer be
required in schools although kids still
do have the option so what's changed
over the last month or so has the
science changed that masks are no longer
effective tools for kids or what's
changed that they're no longer necessary
i would defer to minister copping to
answer that question
no thanks thanks for that question and
you know
we we looked at
in assessing this we looked at the
measures that are in place and the
impact that it has and the benefits we
get from these these these measures and
as the the um premier mentioned uh
earlier this week um you know we need to
let kids be kids we we know
that the uh the impact on like covid uh
impacts kids um that tends to be less
severe um they're less likely to uh to
get and transmit it although with
omicron it is is a higher transmission
rate than we we've seen at delta we we
had heard as well as the concerns of of
the you know mask and the potential
impact on uh on learning uh and also you
know we we've seen studies that there's
a mixed uh review in terms of uh
efficacy and so when we were looking at
you know how do we move forward
in terms of the
taking away
the
health care
provisions and the restrictions that we
had put in place to to manage through
covet we looked at you know those what
that are were the the least effective
and then actually had the greatest the
the greatest cost and so that's why you
know the the first step was dealing with
the rep and removing the rep uh and then
uh as well uh effective february 14th
removing the requirement for muskin
schools and for
children 12 and under
thanks minister a follow-up matt
i do um dr
minister copping i'm not sure if you
have any school age children dr hinch i
believe you do i'm just curious if your
children will continue to wear a mask in
schools
uh so so my children again
i do have school-aged children
whether they will wear a mask or not
that we haven't had that conversation
yet but the uh uh basically leave it as
their choice um to if they want to wear
a mask a lot because it goes to degree
of comfort and and this goes to the
message that i said in my remarks and
also dr dr hinshaw
there are
individuals who may have
different levels of readiness to move
forward in this regard they may have
different levels of concern in terms of
the impact on you know if they're
themselves or on on others uh so we need
to be understanding about people you
know in the show the choices that that
they want to make uh in this regards on
an individual basis uh so i do have
children and and i haven't had that
conversation with them yet but i
probably do so this weekend
thanks minister i will go to the next
caller please
thank you dustin cook post media
hi thank you for taking my question my
questions for minister copping
minister tomorrow edmondson city council
will
debate possibly implementing its own
proof of vaccination program after the
province
got rid of it earlier this week
the premier has spoken out against this
saying that the city doesn't have the
data what data specifically does the
province have that was the rationale to
make this decision that the city doesn't
and why not release that data so the
city can see it
yeah so so you know we took a look at in
our assessment of the the rep
and you know as
the premier indicated earlier this week
but it's also been discussed uh
discussed previously you know the
purpose of the rep
which was incredibly effective when we
actually put it in place in in the uh
during the delta wave uh was to reduce
transmission um allow businesses to
continue to operate so either have a uh
be vaccinated with a
with a qr code or have a um
a test to show that uh test negative
test uh and so they continue to so uh
businesses continue to operate we can
people be involved uh in you know going
to restaurants and and doing other uh
other entertainment venues for example
what we we've seen in terms of the the
data with omicron it is far more
transmissible
in that
the rep as currently structured with two
doses two doses you're still feeling
seeing a large number of uh a
breakthrough cases um some studies were
showing with pfizer with two doses and
and this was in in december uh was you
know ballpark 30 percent uh effective at
um reducing transmission although just
let's be very clear you know vaccines
have assisted us greatly through the
omicron wave
primarily for the reason that it helps
protect against severe outcomes in which
we haven't seen a huge impact although
it's been challenging but huge impact on
our on our health care system so when we
took a look at the original purpose of
the rep was to reduce transmission uh
but given that vaccines uh the two doses
of vaccines were not very effective in
terms of doing that that's why we we
we um uh removed this um
because it we didn't see the
effectiveness and also as mentioned by
the premier it creates some divisiveness
uh within society we need to start
moving forward to learn to live with
omicron we see the hospitalizations new
hospitalizations you know has been
coming down uh every day for the past
two weeks um we've seen uh you know we
have a
general trend line down in terms of
hospitalizations uh people actually in
hospitals at this point in time uh so we
don't you know it's time to move uh and
reduce the measures and then given the
lack of effectiveness of the rep uh
that's why we that was the first on our
list to actually remove
thanks minister uh follow-up dustin
i do thank you this one is for dr
hinshaw
dr hinshaw evanston city council is also
asking um to see the recommendations
that you made to the cabinet committee
um were your recommendations agreed to
and if not will you agree to release
them publicly
all of the recommendations i make to
committees of cabinet are protected
under cabinet confidence
and it's not
something that i have discretion about
so
i'm not able to break the oath that i
swore for cabinet confidence with
respect to releasing my recommendations
that wouldn't be a decision of mine
thanks dr henshaw we'll go to the next
caller
jason marcus off mclean
uh good afternoon thanks for taking my
call uh this question for mr copping i
would like to know if the uh if the
restriction relaxations and other rule
changes on tuesday were
based on recommendations from dr hincha
and while i can appreciate that you
might be inclined to refer to cabinet
confidence i would like to appreciate as
well that albertans have heard several
times when you were you probably said
that you're following her
recommendations so please understand how
an answer like that might sound to many
albertans
yeah well thank you for the question you
know again
we we take very seriously the
recommendations made by our chief
medical officer of health um you know we
as a as a cabinet committee
are balancing the
needs of albertans not only protecting
uh health and protecting uh people from
uh
the delta and omicron and and covet uh
but also mental health because the the
um
the cost that they have with putting in
uh restrictive uh restrictive measures
uh and then also the overall economy and
so in this case we we looked at the the
rep um and the the lack of effectiveness
as currently constructed with with two
doses um in terms of reducing
transmission uh seeing that that wasn't
effective when we made the change and
and i just want to point out that you
know we have made um changes uh like
this throughout uh the majority of of
waves that go back to wave three uh we
had a phased approach uh prudent you
know they were doing the same thing this
time a prudent phased approach in terms
of removing measures um
and and recognize that you know as we've
gone through this each wave has been
different um we've had new we have more
tools available to us now than ever
not only we've increased the rate of uh
vaccinations and
and uh third boosters uh but we also
event antiviral drugs and and then also
the nature of the threat has changed
where uh you know covid uh you know the
delta wave was far more severe uh
omicron is is is is less severe uh and
has different form of impact so you know
we as a as a coveted cabinet committee
take all this into uh into account and
then make and make the decisions
accordingly
thanks minister follow up jason uh yes
thank you i i believe this question
would be for uh for dr henshaw unless
it's a political one as well i wonder
how long the uh data dashboard uh
probably canada's best from alberta on
coveta will last we've seen that
saskatchewan has phased it out and
stopped uh regular daily reporting even
to its officials um
and given that there have been some
similarities in how the two provinces
have moved i would like to know the
future going forward for the alberta
covet data dashboard thank you
thank you for the compliment i'm sure
all of the analytics team who work very
very hard on that appreciate the the nod
because that has been a tremendous
amount of work so just want to recognize
the team that works on that
i don't know that a decision has been
made about timing so that's not
something that that i'm aware of in
terms of a final decision i'm not sure
if minister copping would have anything
to add
yeah the only thing i will add is that
you know at some point in time um you
know as we move into the endemic phase
uh it will make sense to actually have
less reporting
at this
current juncture i think it's important
that we continue to maintain reporting
as we go through the
uh our approach uh in terms of you know
going from phase one to phase two to
phase three but there will be a point in
time where
that level of detail reporting will not
be necessary as we move into an endemic
phase
thanks minister uh i was mistaken i
think we have a reporter in the room in
calgary
so we'll go to to the reporter sorry i
don't know your name but in calgary if
you want to go ahead please ask your
question
it's jesse weisner with global news oh
hi justin um
this is for both the mr coffee and dr
hinshaw i'm hoping for clarity on
specifically what's needed to move to
step two when it comes to
hospitalizations is there a previous
benchmark number like we've seen in
previous waves or what specifically
constitutes a continued decrease like do
we need to see dropping numbers every
day for two weeks
yeah so so thanks for the question we
don't have a specific uh number in mind
um hospitalizations uh you know are is
going to be a key indicator um that we
need to see a decreased strain on the on
the health care system but we'll also be
looking at other indicators so so both
leading indicators you know uh the
number of pcr tests what the wastewater
data is uh is showing it that's going to
be important as well as the new hospital
it's not only actual hospitalizations
but new hospitalization rates so we're
going to take that all into account uh
as we move through it but we need to see
you know trend lines continuing to go
down
thanks minister uh jesse follow-up
uh yeah just on the qr code comment four
so you said uh the vaccination qr code
app will not be accessible anymore i
know the premier said businesses could
continue asking for proof of vaccination
if they would like to but how is that
possible without being able to
authenticate the vaccination code in the
app
so two ways so first of all even though
the the app is uh no longer available um
the way that it works you do not need it
to talk back to the server to a server
so once someone's got a download on the
phone and actually uh the um
most locations who are using the qr code
have already downloaded and have it
available so that will continue to work
um
for quite some period of time
we just won't be updating the app and
you can't download it new again
and then alternately if other businesses
continue to uh through the trans this
transition phase continue to uh um
ask for it they can they can also we
will be uh continuing to
allow uh
albertans and maintain the the um the
ability to print out the uh the qr code
uh and print out the actual like if you
if you look at the qr code it has all
the dates and the numbers in there as
well so they can actually just do a
visual check um so this you know if for
so for those businesses that i want to
continue to use it um that the app is
still the app is still the app is there
and it still works even though you can't
download it or they can do a visual
check um on the on the code
thanks minister uh so since we caught
one extra question in the room we'll
take one last uh caller and then we'll
wind up after that so uh take the last
caller please
thank you dylan short post media
hi mister you spoke about this a little
bit during your opening remarks but
i've heard from from several people
within the health care system that
basically just say you know the plan
they don't have
really
coming in early we've heard that you
know multiple lead indicators are
showing that we are in in step for a
decline within the hospital i guess just
i hope you could explain a little bit
more why you decided to move forward
with this this week where i've been
waiting a couple more weeks to maybe
give the hospital a little bit of a
break
yeah so
again you know we've been like with any
wave we start planning
we know that the wave will come up and
then we know
the wave will go down and we start
planning ahead of time in terms of okay
what are the measures we're going to
take place we have seen since january
16th um a declining cases we've seen
even though that's that number like so
our waived in terms of community spread
appears to have peaked about then and
that's and that's backed up by by
wastewater data and then for more than
two weeks we've actually seen new
hospitalizations dropping like a rock um
and uh and that's so we know that the
actual uh
in hospitals is also going to follow
follow that trend and so
and our approach generally is is we try
to
to manage this um so that
you know we put the measures in place
that are required because the because
each
you know the measures that we put in
place they have a cost uh and they have
a cost on an impact on social activity
they have a constant impact on economic
activity and so we try to put them in
place you know when necessary and then
reduce them as as soon as we we are able
um so given all these these trends um we
know that the numbers are are going to
come down i fully appreciate and once
again i thank all of our health care
workers the the uh
for the work that they are doing into
supporting our system but those numbers
are going to come down and so by making
this move now we are trying to to reduce
um the impact uh and the negative
impacts that these measures have and i
guess i'll make other one other point
you know
we went from the fourth wave um with
almost no changes in um the the health
care measures straight into the fifth
wave and we actually increased them
and so we are mindful that there may be
another wave um i am hopeful uh you know
based on all the conversations that um
you know dr tam for example has
indicated that that we are likely moving
into an endemic phase but there's no
guarantee of that so you know trying to
limit the impact to the greatest extent
on uh on albertans um and then um you
know part of our our job and and the job
that the premier gave me as minister of
health is is to do contingency planning
for whatever comes at us next so you
know we're moving now because it's safe
to do so
and we're trying to limit the negative
impacts that these badgers have on
albertans to the greatest extent
possible
thanks minister so for the final
question of the day dylan your follow-up
yeah it's in terms of the rep you know
the counter arguments for removing it
based on the fact that you know two
doses doesn't provide the greatest
protection against omicron i've heard
from several people that say well why
wouldn't the government amend it to
include a booster dose to get into some
of these places could you explain why
your government chose to get rid of it
rather than do that would rather than
amend it to have a third dose
so
you know i i fully appreciate and i've
heard that argument as well
you know why haven't we do that because
we're actually coming out of the fifth
wave right so it you know adding more
restrictions on doesn't make any sense
when um the wave is peaked
new hospitalizations have come down um
you know community spread is coming down
so so in that context uh
and you're quite right from a
theoretical standpoint adding the third
dose will you know to an rep
would uh help reduce transmission in
those settings but if we don't need to
reduce the transmissions anymore why
would you do it that you wouldn't
because at the end of the day you know
we you know our focus and it has always
been on
on protecting our health care system uh
capacity uh and protecting albertans
albertans you know can get their
protection fruit through through
vaccines and again we urge uh all
albertans to get their to get their uh
boosters if they haven't to get back and
get vaccinate vaccinated uh and in
addition to that
you know our
you know we have protected our health
care system the numbers are coming down
so we don't need additional restrictions
uh or a different additional measures
what we need to do is reduce those
measures at this point in time
thanks minister we'll wrap up the
questions there as always if you need if
you need anything else and we weren't
able to get to you please follow up
separately so thanks minister and thanks
dr hinshaw